Providing clear feedback to
users is one part of building
great functions.
I'm going to take a look at
the function from the last
video that was used to compute
a confidence interval for the
mean using a sample of data.
What if a user provided a
percentage instead of a
proportion for the
confidence level?
Currently the user simply gets
a warning, and the reason
behind the warning isn't going
to be obvious to new R users.
Instead, it'd be helpful to
stop the execution of the
function and clearly communicate
what is wrong.
I'll do this by stopping the
function if the level of the
argument takes a value less than
zero or greater than one.
To stop the execution of a
function and return an error,
use the Stop function.
The argument of the Stop
function is a character string
to communicate why the
error was generated.
Here I'll communicate that the
level variable should have
been represented by a proportion
between 0 and 1.
Now, when a user inputs a level
value that is invalid,
it stops and returns an error.
I'm also a little concerned that
a user might provide a
level that takes a value
like 0.05 or 0.1.
They might think they are
supposed to provide a
significance level, rather
than a confidence level.
If the confidence level is
smaller than 0.5, I'd like to
warn the user that they should
rethink their input.
I can do this using the
Warning function.
In the next video, I'll
introduce how to pass an
arbitrary number of arguments
to a function.